[Music]
hi my name is Samuel Leeds and in this
video I want to talk about some of the
bad sides the dangers to property
investing I now personally be investing
in property for over a decade
I'm also the best-selling author of
these property box by low-rent hoeing
and also how to get financially free in
seven days so you haven't read these
already get them from Amazon and you can
read these so what are the big dangers
and risks well I think every worst
nightmare for a property investor or a
landlord is that their property will get
trashed also what happens if there's a
bad tenant you know if there's someone
in the property that's not paying rent
or there's somebody that's just
generally being an awful tenant they
can't go how do you stop that happening
but even more so what do you do if it
does let me first talk about bad tenants
the only thing that's worse than no
tenant is a bad tenant how can I tell
it'd be bad well really the only two
things that I think they can do to be a
bad tenant generally speaking is they
can not look after the property and
trash the property or they can just stop
paying any rent so what do you do when
that happens
ideally it won't happen I've got dozens
and dozens and dozens of tenants and
it's very very rare that that happens
and the reason is is because before I
ever move a tenant into one of my
properties I always make sure that the
letting agent that's the tenant so what
do you have to look forward moving a
tenant in well firstly never move a
tenant in out of desperation so
sometimes I see investors where they
over exaggerate the rent so they think
that the rent is going to be say 500
pounds and usually that's because
they've been lied to and then bought the
property from a sorcerer or an agent so
they put the property an overinflated
price and then the property sits empty
for months and then what happens is the
investor the landlord becomes desperate
and there's nothing worse than being
desperate because when you a desperate
investor you have a property that's
empty and you become desperate
you can move bad tenants in so if you've
got an empty property I would say always
hold out for a good tenant never move
somebody in in a rush so the things you
have to do to bet them is number one I
now I'm not discriminating against
people that don't work it might be that
your niche is students or DSS tenants
but personally my properties are pretty
much all professional properties so I'm
looking for can they afford to pay the
rent if they can't have they got a
guarantor you can afford to pay the rent
so come in for it number two I want to
see a previous landlord check I want to
see a reference now something that I do
personally is rather than getting a
landlord reference from their previous
landlord I don't do that I get a
previous previous landlord check and the
reason is is because it might be that
their previous landlord ie their
existing landlord who will be previous
when they move hates their guts and is
desperate to get rid of them because
they're a terrible tenant and what
happens is sometimes a landlord will
give a good reference just because he
wants them to move on because he can't
wait to get rid of them so as more
accurate reference will come from a
previous to the previous so go back
maybe a few years and asked the tenant
to get a previous previous language
check also credit check had they ever
not paid for things before have they got
a good credit get a work reference so
when they say I'm working for this
company ask for a reference do they work
here another good member of staff so
when you've got these kind of references
credit checks potential guarantor it's
getting massively massively take the
risk out of the tenant not paying any
rent so if you do these things it should
ensure that your tenant pays the rent so
you're pretty safe now how do you make
sure that the tenant doesn't trash the
property well of course you've got a
travelled reference sometimes my own
agents even visit the properties that
they're currently in so if someone
applies to live in one of my properties
they'll go and visit them at their
existing property just to see what the
conditions like if you can do that it's
absolutely amazing because how the
condition of that property is it's going
to be the same as your property because
they'll treat it the same another thing
is to take deposit so that if they do
when they move out they damage the
carpets or their kids have drawn on the
walls you can then get that fixed with
their deposit if you can take your
deposit always make sure that you do
mr. it and you can do that at my deposit
oh that you came now something to bear
in mind it is when a tenant trashes the
property I have never ever in my ten
eleven years of being a landlord had a
tenant who's a good tenant look after
the property everything's fine and then
one day they just trash it I've never
had that what happens is the tenant
moves in and they just don't look after
it and the kids draw on the walls and
the dogs we on the carpets or whatever
and over months and years the property
just generally just falls into a worse
and worse state of repair until they
hand they notice in a move out and then
when they move out you go and visit the
property in you're like oh my goodness
this is trashed it's nothing like it was
and then you need to spend ten thousand
pounds really and got the property which
it wipes out the rent of the whole of
that three year period of when the
tenant was there so how do you avoid
that happening it's very very simple
when you move a tenant in just make sure
that not only if you vetted them
properly but also that you have regulate
inspections and mostly an agents will do
this to begin with
you can even inspect the property after
a two or three month period then three
months then six months and then you
could just do it every six months
because that way when the agent goes to
the property they'll they'll have an
inventory which means that they'll know
exactly what the state of repair was
like when they turn moved in if it
begins to get a little bit bad if
there's a bit of drawing on the wall or
there's a little bit of a dog smell when
you said you didn't want dogs you can
then address it there and then before it
gets too light and I think if you do
these things if you do regular
inspections you vet the tenants well you
take the security deposits you're very
very safe to make sure that nothing goes
wrong however while you're massively
eliminating the risk of having bad
tenants or a trashed property there of
course is still a very small chance that
something could go wrong though the
tenant could stop paying on the
tentative damage the property so what do
you do if the damage is over the
security deposit what do you do if the
tenants still despite all the checks
just stops paying you the rent well it's
very very clear what you should do when
it moves in you will have an AS
an assured shorthold tenancy agreement
in place which will address what happens
if the tenant does breaches their
agreement and if the tenant stops paying
rents usually you'll have to give them a
two month notice period and you'll say
look you've got two months to either pay
or get out of the property now if after
two months I still don't pay then what
happens well I had to do this probably I
could count on one hand how many times
this happens but you will then have to
take them to a small claims court put in
a claim against them and it might take
three four five months but ultimately
the law will force them to pay their
rent and to leave the property now worst
case for you is that you might lose a
few months rent and when they leave they
might end up saying well I can't pay in
which case they'll have a County Court
judgment against them so they'll never
be able to even take our phone contract
again certainly for five years you've
lost a little bit of rent but ultimately
the law is there in place the reason we
have contracts and the reason we have
court systems is to protect the tenants
and it's also to protect you against
people that just won't pay so the law is
there in place for that if they trash
the property just out the blue one day
and the property is absolutely messed up
what do you do well you all have it's
them and you'll take their deposit but
again worst case it is possible that you
will end up having to pay out of your
own pocket for the damages you can take
into court but are they gonna be able to
afford to pay it so I think I just use
your common sense if the damages of two
thousand pounds and they paid a thousand
pound security deposit what did you do
with that with that thousand pound
difference personally by the the effort
time and money to tap into court I
wouldn't do it so that is just a little
bit of a risk which is why I always say
you should have a 10% buffer which you
you save up towards repairs on the
property so that when the tenant moves
out it is wear and tear you can invest
it that way so is property investing
risky not really if you do it properly
it's certainly a lot less risky than
putting your money in the bank where
your money is just gonna shrink and you
cannot going to get any return at all
from it investing in property comes with
big rewards but there also is a little
bit of risk the key is to eliminate that
by doing it properly so I hope that
video has been helpful please do comment
your thoughts below smash that like
button and don't forget to subscribe so
you'll never miss an upload again thank
you so much for watching this video it's
mentoring on a Monday every single week
at 7 p.m. on a Monday between 8 p.m. I'm
gonna be live answering all your
comments and questions don't forget to
subscribe right over here so you'll
never miss one of these videos I'll see
you next week at 7 p.m. also if you
haven't got a copy of my book you need
this in your life you can get it from
Amazon for ten-pound 99 or a gift from
made absolutely free down below in the
description link I'll see you next week
monday at 7 p.m.